in the midst of this digital revolution  that we're going through now it's good  to remember that it was Francis who was  one of the first ones to ever embrace  this whole digital change before most  people even knew it was coming the one  thing that he always told me it was our  one difference that we had in life  parents who said George you know how to  make money but you don't know how to  spend it and I think over the years here  it's become very clear I've learned how  to spend money and Francis has learned  how to make it and we both came to the  same place  he's truly the godfather of a generation  who changed the course of motion picture  history and on behalf of the Academy's  Board of Governors it is my honor to  prevent to pretend Francis Coppola an  innovator an artist an icon most  importantly a rebel and most importantly  to me a friend and a brother with the  Irving G Thalberg Memorial Award thank  you  you